tell everyone what you created and why
so on a recent trip to a toy store I saw
that you know no dolls resembled my
students is hearing devices they have
hearing aids and cochlear implants so I
went home and crafted them myself for to
have my students resemble the toys that
they play with that is amazing stop
right there and go well it just doesn't
exist but you like went the extra mile I
know teachers don't have a lot of spare
time in general my momma was the teacher
so the fact that you went above and
beyond that's amazing so Genesis had 115
followers when she posted this tweet but
within 24 hours the post had 30,000
retweets and 150 thousand likes
so Genesis how did your students react
to the dolls um they loved them those of
cochlear implants reach for the dolls of
cochlear implants and those with hearing
aids reach for those with hearing aids
so it really shows how much they
identify with the toys yeah they got to
see that was like one of my favorite
parts of being I got to this phone
called ugly dolls and it's like the
thing about the dolls was like everybody
kind of related to one of them and they
weren't your normal doll and I thought
that was brilliant what you did for them
and it's a special and are they still
playing with the doll how to be laughs
we have tea parties birthday parties
they make cakes for them it's so much
fun they have not been put down syns
man representation is so important and
every facet of what I'm saying that for
I metaphorically every way
Breger ingenuity and the passion for
your students at teachers like you
really do make a difference you make
kids feel special and it really does and
can change the trajectory of their life
so thank you so much you know her from
Glee Christopher guest's brilliant
movies and now from the marvelous mrs.
Mazal which you can watch on amazon
prime video so say hello to a woman who
has become a fast friend of the show
Jane Lynch Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I am so appreciative you came back again
thank you for that means you must not
hated it no I enjoyed it somewhat okay
good I was like that's the goal and well
you're the best at this what you
actually actually Genesis you are you
deaf in your right ear I am worse yeah
Genesis was just home at the doll thing
and that kind of cool I just think it's
so wonderful it's the sweetest thing I'm
definitely my right ear but one of the
things that I love watching on YouTube
is when they put the cochlear implants
in like a baby for the very first time
yeah oh and they cry their mother's
voice for the very first time yeah one
of the most moving things in the world
and it's also one of the things we take
advantage of like everybody that has it
and you don't have to worry about that
right exactly it's a really be grateful
I am really grateful to I have one ear
and it's Bionic it's so you know not to
the place that it totally made up for
the one that doesn't work so and it's
been all my life so I didn't have to
have like that adjustment yeah music is
important to you anyways I know so like
what if I if you had to tell me like
what's the song you've played like the
most right now probably Elton John
someone saved my life tonight oh oh I
mean I rock out on that one
it's great isn't it yeah it's like four
songs in one yeah it goes all over the
place it's like an epic poem I don't
love it
that's not main you all know that song
yeah it's yeah well maybe if people who
are like my age but even the youngsters
know it too right yeah Elton freaking
Joel McCrea
John yeah damn and ER subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going